zu setzen
herzlich willkommen zu dieser
bundespressekonferenz an diesem
dienstagmorgen ich begrüße den
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach
die präsenz robert koch institut und die
büros apweiler direktor european
bioinformatics institute des deutschen
rabatt des europäischen laboratoriums
für molekularbiologie in cambridge sein
sonst alle herzlich willkommen es geht
um die aktuelle kronlage
minister
vielen dank herr fällt auf dass wir hier
gast bei ihnen sein dürfen das wissen
wir sehr zu schätzen und vielen dank
auch also dass wir heute zu
ihren fragen begegnen dürfen ich freue
mich insbesondere
aus ahrweiler hier in der runde damit
dabei zu haben wir kennen uns seit
langer zeit und gut und so ich hätte
heraus dass er wegen seiner expertise in
der modellierung zum beispiel der frage
wie wird es zu neuen varianten kommen
und er ist das sehr ausgewiesen nicht
nur das haus kauft sondern ganz
allgemein und von daher vielen dank die
woraus hast du hier bist und ich freue
mich auf ein lila wieder an meiner seite
zu wissen
ganz kurz wie ist die situation also wir
sind in einer relativ schwierigen
situation
dass positives wie negatives
nebeneinander zu sehen
wir haben nach wie vor steigende
fallzahlen wir haben auch eine
hospitalisierung rate mit der wir nicht
wirklich zufrieden sein können die
lage ist noch nicht wirklich unter der
kontrolle auf der positiven seite ist es
entwickelt sich ungefähr so wie wir uns
das als wir die maßnahmen die jetzt noch
gelten beschlossen haben erwartet hatten
ich hatte ja schon mit januar darauf
hingewiesen dass wir diesmal die
weil er steuern mit einem modell was im
robert koch institut entwickelt worden
ist also von einer arbeitsgruppe wenn
meier und also der brockmann herum
institute auch noch andere gute arbeits
gucken dass wir hier nicht unerwähnt
lassen aber das modell habe ihr
veröffentlicht teil wenig die autoren
und damit haben wir modelliert wie
gefährlich kann eigentlich auch mikron
sein damit unser system nicht überlastet
wird und wie viele zufälle erwarten wir
wie viele auch spezialisierungen waren
ist der höhepunkt der wähler zu erwarten
und im großen und ganzen beschreibt das
modell das was wir jetzt sehen gut also
wir sind nach wie vor also nicht vor dem
höhepunkt der übung hatte ich ja schon
vor fast vier wochen also vorher gesagt
auf mitte februar das wird
wahrscheinlich also auch der zeitpunkt
sein wo wir den höhepunkt erreichen es
kann sich noch etwas ändern durch baa2
das kosten würde bedeuten dass der
höhepunkt etwas später kommt aber wir
fahren ungefähr also die maßnahmen die
wir brauchen um also diese welle so zu
steuern aus zu steuern wie wir uns das
gedacht hatten somit die maßnahmen die
wir ergriffen haben funktionieren das
muss man klar sagen das ist also richtig
und das ist auch eine leistung
dahingehend war deutschland hat eine
schwierige aufgabe in der bewältigung
der mikrowelle wir haben halt an der
sehr alte bevölkerung die zweitälteste
also bevölkerung in europa gemessen am
median der altersverteilung in
deutschland und wir haben eine sehr hohe
im lücke bei den älteren die zahl der
ungeimpften ist im vergleich zu anderen
europäischen ländern deutlich höher
die also dunkelziffer der also genießen
dann mit eingerechnet muss auf jeden
fall davon ausgegangen werden dass wir
in deutschland eine drei- bis viermal so
zahl von ungeimpften bei den besonders
gefährdeten ältere menschen haben von
daher sind wir noch immer gefährdet und
wir können also breiter lockerungen wie
sie derzeit diskutiert werden zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht vertrieben
nicht wundere mich über die diskussion
die zum teil in der politik jetzt zu
beobachten ist wir sind noch vor dem
höhepunkt der reisewelle wir haben jeden
tag zwischen 100 und also 150 tote zu
beklagen
viel zu viel wir also uns gelingt es
also die welle einigermaßen zu
kontrollieren mit den maßnahmen die wir
am platz haben das heißt sollte es jetzt
zu einer schnellen öffnung kommen zu
einer schnellen rücknahme wesentlicher
maßnahmen dann würden die welle dort
nicht verlängern also würden dann
wahrscheinlich nicht nur eine
rückfallgefahr sowie es tieren sondern
wir würden dann also quasi ein schnelles
abflachen der welle wie wir es ja jetzt
im prinzip anstreben das würden wir
damit nicht erreichen können somit ist
die diskussion die wir derzeit haben
öffnungen aus meiner sicht fehl am platz
also die werden natürlich deutlich vor
ostern öffnen können aber wenn wir jetzt
schnell öffnen dann verlängern wir nur
die welle und schaden uns selbst und das
wird auch in der bevölkerung gar nicht
wirklich also als erfolg betrachtet
werden also wir haben jetzt eine
funktionierende erfolgreiche strategie
diese ohne not jetzt zu gefährden kann
nicht unser ziel sein wir haben in
dieser woche eine also test verordnung
zu erwarten wo wir uns lange überlegt
haben wie können wir das machen das sind
auch die daten eingeflossen die ich
gerade beschrieben habe wie viel wie
hoch sind die fallzahlen also wann
erwarten wir den höhepunkt wir haben die
zahl der pcs noch einmal in verbund mit
dem labor anbietern also erhöhen können
wir können derzeit ungefähr drei
millionen pcr tests pro woche
durchführen darüber hinaus können wir um
die
350.000 pocket tests pro woche
durchführen so dass man auf ein
gesamtvolumen von also
test kommt die also spezifisch über
nukleare die also promikon variante und
andere varianten erfassen können von
ungefähr 3,3 millionen auf der grundlage
haben wir die test strategie uns noch
einmal vorgenommen und kommen in dieser
woche minarett es verordnung die wie
folgt funktionieren wird es wird dabei
bleiben dass es eine priorisierung geben
wird für diejenigen die in
pflegeeinrichtungen
arbeiten und dem medizinischen system wo
menschen gefährdet sind es wird auch
eine priorisierung gebend für diejenigen
die selbst also für den eigenen schutz
besonders gefährdet sind wo eine
medikamentöse therapie notwendig ist
also wenn also die diagnose gestellt
wird werden aber für jeden weiterhin
einen pc heraus bestätigen den test war
diagnose anbieten können das verfahren
dazu funktionieren dass grundsätzlich
ein antigen test dafür die voraussetzung
ist dass das bzs gemacht werden kann das
heißt bei einer bei einem verdachtsfall
beispielsweise symptome oder
verdachtsfall aus anderen gründen wird
zuerst ein antigen test gemacht ist er
dann positiv folgt dann der bestätigende
pcs und das wollen wir bei allen machen
mit den instanzen die wir jetzt haben
und die wir noch erwarten können können
wir das durchhalten somit hätten wir
dann als system was auf der einen seite
sehr effizient ist war die pcs werden
dort eingesetzt wo die feuer so vortest
wahrscheinlichkeit sehr hoch ist dass
ich ein positives ergebnis bekommen das
ist aber auch klar ist hatte ich ein
sehr sicheres system war jeder der
infiziert ist wer weiß auch dass
infiziert war war der pcr die
bestätigung ergeben hat somit ein
effizientes aber auch sicheres system wo
die test verordnung in dieser woche
erfolgt wir sind also sicher dass wir
damit auch die bedürfnisse und wünsche
der bevölkerung erfassen können weil
viele haben wir sorge dass sie wenn sie
die diagnose kommen ohne pcr test nicht
wirklich sicher sein können und ob sie
infiziert sind ja oder nein und daher
werden wir das so vornehm wo der antigen
test ausreicht also allein nicht
ausreicht ist befreit ist und das ist
auch hier immer wieder vorgetragen
worden auch von kollegen drosten wir
sind darum kontakt mit also anderen
spezialisten der also antigen test ist
bei der also beim im späten verlauf
einer stadtgarten oder also in so einer
infektion ist antigen deshalb sehr gut
also festzustellen ob jemand noch
ansteckendes ja oder nein und da ist er
in seiner wertigkeit zum tag der pcr
tests überlegen war der pcr test hat
dann zum teil noch ct werte die schwer
über also die schwere auszuwerten sind
somit ist jeder gedanke dass die
freisetzung über dem artikel
letztes thema
sie haben ja gestern verfolgt das also
ministerpräsident söder also in aussicht
gestellt hat dass er die einrichtungs
bezogenen der impfpflicht in bayern
nicht also umsetzen will er hat quasi
also
vorgetragen dass er den vorzug also
nicht also durchführen möchte das
entspricht einer nicht umsetzung von wir
haben dann auch also aus den kreisen der
cdu gehört dass also der also dass man
dass wir als bund zucker aufgefordert
werden ja in richtung zogen wir
impfpflicht noch einmal zu überdenken
oder möglicherweise zurückzunehmen das
halte ich für sehr problematisch also
ich will erst mal darauf hinweisen die
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht ist
keine schikane gegen das personal
welches in diesen einrichtungen arbeitet
darum geht es nicht sondern uns geht es
um den schutz der dort den also
mitarbeitern anvertrauten menschen jeder
von uns bringt in erinnerung die
dramatisch die probleme gewesen sind aus
uns vor gut einem jahr in diesen
einrichtungen sehr viele menschen leider
gestorben sind und also in den
pflegeeinrichtungen in den einrichtungen
der eingliederungshilfe aber auch wenn
also in der klinik große operation
gemacht werden müssen spreche von der
chemotherapie zum beispiel gemacht
werden muss dann sind die menschen
besonders wohl habe und es geht um den
schutz dieser wohlhabenden personen
denen wir quasi sicherheit anbieten
müssen es geht hier nicht um eine
maßnahme wie wir uns überlegen wie
können wir das leben der pflegekräfte
schwerer machen darum geht es nicht und
also jetzt hier eine situation
entstanden ohne dass neue erkenntnisse
also gekommen wären wo wir sagen uns ist
ich sage einmal der protest gegen die
einrichtungs bezogene nebenpflicht auch
auf der straße wichtiger als der schutz
der menschen die also hier hilflos auf
eine gute versorgung warten und sich
angesteckt werden dürfen das kann nicht
die richtige priorität sein erstes als 8
kann ich sagen ist das also definitiv
also nicht nachvollziehbar es kann nicht
angehen so dass also wir sagen also die
mitarbeiter in diesen einrichtungen
akzeptieren den westlichen wissensstand
nicht und sagen ich glaube nicht an die
impfung das ist für medizinisches
personal keine wirklich vertretbare
position ich kann auch nicht sagen also
ich glaube nicht dass so an dieses oder
jenes medikament sondern als also dass
also mitarbeiter in einer einrichtung da
muss ich schon also dann auch also für
die medizin stehen für die art medizin
stehen die ich also
diddy diddy gilt für diejenigen die wern
vertraut sind zum einen und zum zweiten
es ist auch so es gibt ein vollkommen
falsches signal also es mag gibt das
signal was werden uns der protest gegen
die allgemeine gegen die einrichtungs
prozent licht wichtiger wäre dass wir
diesen protest verhindern wollen als
uns der schutz dieser menschen bedeutsam
ist so dass daher halte ich das so
falsch ist es auch also für
politik insgesamt also sehr
problematisch weil das bedeutet ja dass
also die gesetze gelten aber also dass
sie von ministerpräsidenten nicht
unbedingt umgesetzt werden müssen das
ist natürlich auch eine botschaft die
schwer zu vermitteln ist also wir
verlangen seit vielen monaten von den
menschen einschränkungen also die in
ihre grundfreiheiten hineingehen wir
schließen also
beschließen
diskotheken und clubs
also
wir regulieren den eingang in
zahlreichen restaurants zu erwarten dass
die bevölkerung immer mitglied wenn wir
das gut begründen können wenn werden wir
maßnahmen und vortragen und jetzt macht
es den eindruck als wenn dies für die
ministerpräsidenten möglicherweise nicht
gehalten werden das finde ich persönlich
also ein sehr gefährliches signal und
daher also bin ich damit nicht glücklich
und hoffe dass wir da noch zu einer
lösung kommen die
also die einrichtungs bezogen nämlich
dann dort noch entsprechend umsetzt
vielen dank an minister hält
damen und herren ich bin optimistisch
dass wir die quelle bald überstanden
haben auch wenn der höhepunkt der welle
noch nicht erreicht ist wir sind bislang
vergleichsweise gut durch diesen sturm
gesteuert und wir lernen dabei auch
immer mehr über omikron in den letzten
sieben tagen sind rund 1,2 millionen
fälle ans robert koch institut
übermittelt worden das sind etwa zehn
prozent aller fälle die bislang in
dieser ganzen pandemie in deutschland
registriert wurden wir sehen inzwischen
auch anstiege bei den ost italy sie
rungen
möglicherweise ist dieser anstieg trotz
der
fallzahlen bislang noch vergleichsweise
gering die intensivstation sind aber
nach wie vor belastet dort werden
aktuell rund 2400 co at 19 patientinnen
und patienten behandelt wir müssen
weiter beobachten wie sich die situation
auf den intensivstationen entwickelt und
auch wie sich die zahl der kurve toten
entwickelt was zeigen uns diese
entwicklung und wie sind sie zu bewerten
so erstens der anteil der menschen die
schwer an omikron erkranken ist geringer
als bei delta darauf haben daten aus
anderen ländern bereits hingewiesen und
das sehen wir jetzt auch in unserem
eigenen land bei den ungeimpften ist der
anteil der hospitalisierten mit delta
insgesamt fast doppelt so hoch wie bei
denen die mit omikron infiziert sind in
der gruppe der über 80-jährigen werden
etwa drei von zehn der omicron
infizierten hospitalisiert im vergleich
dazu sind es bei den gelte infizierten
etwa 5 von 10
zweitens zeigen die daten auch wie gut
eine vollständige impfung bzw die
auffrischung vor schweren verläufen und
von todesfällen schützt wir wissen dass
nikon den immunschutz besser umgehen
kann und dass sie auch viele geimpfte
mit omikron infizieren aber wenn
geimpfte aufgefrischte oder genesene
erkranken dann erkannten sie in den
allermeisten fällen eben weniger schwer
die auffrischimpfung schwitzt deutlich
vor dem krankenhaus aufenthalt besonders
ausgeprägt ist dieser effekt in der
gruppe der über 80 jährigen also den die
ja mit am anfälligsten sind in unserer
gesellschaft unsere daten zeigen ein
deutlich höheres risiko für eine schwere
kurve neun zehn erkrankten bei
ungeimpften mitmensch und diese
beobachtung meine damen und herren die
gilt für alle altersgruppen
drittens die gängigen maßnahmen wie
abstand halten maske tragen lüften
hygiene die wirken natürlich auch
bionicon wenn sich nicht so viele
menschen daran halten würden aber mein
ausdrücklicher dank an die solidarität
unserer mitmenschen in unserem land dann
wären die fallzahlen innerhalb kurzer
zeit noch viel rasanter
stiegen das muss man einfach wissen all
diesen aspekten ist es zu verdanken dass
kliniken angesichts dieser extrem hohen
fallzahlen zwar stark belastet aber eben
nicht völlig überlastet sind und
was wir bei der bewertung der momentanen
situation aber wirklich auch immer vor
augen haben müssen ist das zurzeit nach
wie vor hauptsächlich jüngere menschen
erkranken und die erkrankten ja in der
regel nicht so schwer wie ältere und
hochaltrigen die inzidenz bei den
älteren steigen erst allmählich wieder
an und wir können im moment noch nicht
genau abschätzen wie stark diese gruppe
denn betroffen sein wird und wie die
omikron infektionen bei dieser gruppe
verlauf auch die zahl der todesfälle
sie ist im moment rückläufig könnte noch
einmal ansteigen wenn eine größere zahl
von omikron infizierten schwer erkrankt
schauen sie in nachbarländern wie
dänemark vereinten königreich schweden
frankreich
was mir nicht nur im hinblick auf
omikron sorge macht ist dass es bei den
über 60 jährigen immer noch viele
ungeimpfte gibt dabei ist und bleibt die
ihm von der beste und sicherste weg der
immunität zum schutz vor der kurve 19
erkrankung wenn sie geimpft sind dann
denken sie bitte auch immer daran die
auffrischimpfung zu nehmen bitte denken
sie auch daran dass saas kauf 2 nicht
mehr verschwinden wird das auch weiter
neue varianten auftreten werden
tatsächlich stehen wir vor einem
wendepunkt diese phase der pandemie ist
ganz anders als vor zwei jahren
wir kennen das virus deut besser wer
aber in großen teilen der bevölkerung
eine grundimmunisierung
die maßnahmen wir uns wirksam schützen
als nationales public health institut
hat unser robert koch institut die
gesundheit der ganzen bevölkerung im
blick aber auch in der jetzigen phase
der pandemie ist der schutz der
besonders verletzlichen gruppen für uns
von herausragender bedeutung
zu dieser gruppe gehören die alten und
die vor erkrankten die ein erhöhtes
risiko für einen schweren verlauf haben
aber auch die kinder die meistens dem
virus ohne immunität ausgesetzt werden
die meisten kinder werden die infektion
gut überstehen dennoch besteht eine
gewisse unsicherheit und man kann nicht
vorhersagen wer wie betroffen sein wird
und auch bezüglich der langzeitfolgen
longo witt gibt es immer noch
unklarheiten
daher gilt im moment weiterhin je
langsamer sich saas kopf zwei ausbreite
und je mehr menschen können sich noch
impfen lassen in der zeit desto besser
schützen wir die uns am wichtigsten mit
sind das sind damit die verletzlichen
mitmenschen aber wir schützen natürlich
auch die kritischen infrastrukturen das
hatten wir ja auch schon deutlich
ausgeführt in wenigen wochen haben wir
die omikron welle überstanden bleiben
wir ruhig und achtsam und aufmerksam
dann können wir uns entspannt auf ostern
fallen vielen dank herr villa gab einer
guten morgen meine damen und herren ich
bin gebeten worden einige bemerkungen
zur entwicklung der sauerstoff zwei
varianten in die diskussion einfließen
zu lassen bis heute sind weltweit
millionen von sauerstoff zwei genom
sequenziert wurden die die laufende
veränderung des virus im detail
beschrieben haben und zur entdeckung von
mehr als tausend varianten geführt haben
etwa ein dutzend davon sind als
besorgniserregend oder als zu beobachten
klassifiziert worden jetzt schon eine
kernaussage das ist dass weitere
varianten gehe ich stark von den
existieren unterscheiden werden
auftreten werden je mehr menschen
weltweit nicht geimpft sind desto mehr
infektionen und umso rascher entwickeln
sich neue besorgniserregende varianten
daher brauchen wir eine rasche impfung
der weltbevölkerung mit hochwirksamen
stoffen eine weltweite überwachung durch
genome sequenzieren mit schnellen und
freien und offenen austausch der daten
sowohl aus ökologischen gründen als auch
zum forschungszwecken nun einige details
dazu in deutschland neben vielen anderen
ländern auch haben sie schon gehört
dominieren die unter unicom
zusammengefassten sub linien b1 b2 und
andere daten aus dänemark haben uns
gezeigt dass sich die ansteckende
variante ba2 mit etwas größerer
geschwindigkeit noch ausbreitet
möglicherweise ist hinsichtlich der
klinischen charakteristik kein hinweis
da dass es nicht dass sich infektion mit
baa2 von infektion mit baa1 und
durchscheinen in deutschland ist der
derzeitige anteil von baa2 ca 10 bis 20
prozent eher 20 prozent wird
voraussichtlich nächsten wochen bis
monaten dominieren
das schon gerade gesagt worden ist in
deutschland ist omikron wesentlich
langsamer angestiegen als in vielen
anderen ländern was meines erachtens
zeigt dass hier griff den maßnahmen
wirkten und wirken und ich möchte auch
noch mal was lothar graap gesagt hat
aufgreifen die dadurch gewonnene zeit
sollte man nutzen um weiterhin so viele
menschen wie möglich zu impfen um so die
ausbreitung zu verlangsamen vor schweren
krankheitsverläufen zu schützen und
klinik aufnahmen und auch
personalausfälle nicht zu schnell und zu
hoch steigen zu lassen es ist noch nicht
vorbei aber
man hat schon mal ein bisschen hoffnung
war jetzt aber jetzt einen blick zurück
und auch dann in die zukunft wichtig ist
wirklich die globale verteilung der
gruppen besorgniserregenden vorhanden
sie wurden zuerst im vereinigten
königreich im südlichen afrika in indien
in teilen südamerikas nachgewiesen
außerdem gab es noch andere varianten
aus verschiedenen weltregionen diese
falls sie etwas früher aufgetreten wären
auch das potenzial gehabt hätten zu
besorgnis erregend varianten zu werden
man braucht also auch globale
überwachung durch genomsequenzierung
sowie das ist wirklich wichtig
zusätzlich auch umfassende
epidemiologische und klinische daten zur
charakterisierung die daten zur nikon
aus südafrika beispielsweise waren
extrem hilfreich um in ländern wie
deutschland rasch zu reagieren und zb
die booster impfung vorzuziehen
mein kollege moritz gerst und er wie
kaum ein anderer die varianten
entwicklung während der pandemie
analysiert hat hat mich nochmals daran
erinnert wie bemerkenswert ist es ist
dass alle besorgniserregenden varianten
vom ursprünglichen virustyp b1 abstammen
es gibt keine graduelle evolution von
einer mutation zu anderen von bca zu
alpha + + + die bedeutende neue
besorgniserregende varianten
hervorgerufen habe hervorgebracht haben
diese varianten diesen neuen
besorgniserregenden sind alle durch
sogenannte sprung evolution aus b1 aus
dem ursprungs typ entstanden omikron
beispielsweise muss ich mindestens ein
jahr irgendwo in abgeschiedenheit
entwickelt haben und wie es dann
plötzlich mehr als 30 mutation auf den
keiner anderen verfahren zuvor zu in
dieser kombination zu finden waren daher
muss man auch in zukunft auf
überraschungen gefasst sein
omikron hat uns gezeigt wie stark eine
neue variante bestehende immunität
umgehen kann man musste ja damit rechnen
dass noch weitere varianten entstehen
werden die omikron die bestehende
immunität umgehen könnten aber unter
umständen auch die aggressivität von
delta haben die genaue entstehung der
besorgniserregenden varianten ist
eigentlich unbekannt es gibt zwei
mögliche erklärungen
das eine ist dir die des tresors und die
andere die elektronischen infektionen es
gibt diverse beispiele für infektionen
wild und nutztieren die etwa
europäischen märz kamen oder gerade
gestern wurde von hongkong von 50
infektionen von hamster über hamster
gerichtet
da ich selbst existieren aber auch
zahlreiche fallstudien zu chronischen
virusinfektion von immungeschwächten
patienten über monate hinweg die
veränderte viren hervorbringen und dabei
insbesondere die charakteristika erzeugt
haben die auch einen besorgniserregenden
varianten zu finden werden es ist
wirklich erschütternd beispiele von
patienten zu hören die im südlichen
afrika die aufgrund von maxi mangelndem
zugang zu hiv therapien und der daraus
resultierenden und welche bis zu 300
tage mit source code 2 infiziert waren
man muss daher nicht nur über den
weltweiten zugang zu impfungen und
therapien gegen saas kauf zwei
nachdenken sondern auch über breitere
globale gesundheitsfürsorge
nur wenn wir global denken und helfen
die gesundheitsfürsorge in allen ländern
entscheidend zu verbessern dann können
wir die entstehung neuer
besorgniserregende varianten
zurückbringen es ist absolut regte sich
richtig zu sagen keiner ist auf diesem
planeten sicher wenn nicht alle auf
diesem planeten sicher sind
abschließend noch mal kurz anmerken wie
wichtig gute programme zur überwachung
durch genom sequenzieren und die
verknüpfung mit epidemiologischen die
klinischen daten sind sie zitieren oft
studien aus dem vereinten königreich
oder aus dänemark da diese solche guten
programmen haben zum einen weiter
zementiert und analysiert wird aber
andererseits haben diese länder auch
einen datenschutz verständnis das ist
erlaubt die viralen sequenzen mit
epidemiologischen klinischen genetischen
daten zu verknüpfen und dadurch stark
der gegenwert der sequenzierung sowie
der anderen datenerhebungen immens
dänische wissenschaftler haben
beispielsweise eine große studie
veröffentlicht die uns gezeigt haben
dass die ansteckungsrate von baa2
haushalten deutlich erhöht ist solche
forschungsarbeiten sind leider in
deutschland schlicht und ergreifend
nicht möglich und viel potenzial das in
deutschland existiert wird nicht benutzt
ganz zum abschluss nochmal meine
kernaussagen weitere varianten werden
auftreten und die erfahrung lehrt dass
man auf überraschungen gefasst sein muss
um so mehr menschen weltweit nicht
geimpft sind und infiziert werden um so
eher entstehen neue besorgnis jährigen
varianten daher brauchen eine rasche
impfung der weltbevölkerung sowie eine
globale bewachung des genom
sequenzierung mit schnellen freien und
offenen austausch der daten vielen
vielen dank die erste frage geht an
herrn
lauterbach kann man
eine politische frage haben ihnen die
fdp kabinettskollegen eigentlich von
einem besseren lkw präsidenten
vorschlagen oder warum segen die am
stuhl von wila oder wider wir nehmen sie
das wahr machen sie darüber
man sollte vielleicht den politischen
teil also immer herr wille hat mein
volles vertrauen es sitzt ja auch erneut
hier und die also fdp das lasse ich
unkommentiert für mich ist auf jeden
fall entscheiden dass wir gut
zusammenarbeiten
und heute morgen das ist wieder eine
demonstration dieser zusammenarbeit
ja also das robert koch institut
arbeitet wissenschafts basiert
inhaltlich das machen wir jetzt seit
zwei jahren in einem spotlight wie wir
das natürlich vorher noch nicht hatten
und das wird auch so bleiben und ich
meine ich habe heute geburtstag und ich
habe das glück jetzt mit ihnen hier
zusammen bei 1 61 geburtstag zu
verbringen denn was kann es denn
angenehm wo das geben wir sind uns doch
so sehr ans herz gewachsen
insofern ist das alles in ordnung
gratulieren wir ganz herzlich auch und
kolleginnen und kollegen der villa ich
will mal eine frage ich habe also eine
nachricht aber ist so schlau dass jetzt
einfach dieses so laufen zu lassen dass
sie das nicht kommentieren wollen weil
hier geht es ja nicht um irgendwelche
fdp aussagen sondern das kommt ja aus
ihrem kabinett und sprechen sie jetzt
nur sie hätten wieder vertrauen aus oder
gilt das dann für die gesamte
bundesregierung also ich lasse das ja
nicht laufen sondern ich habe jede frage
beantwortet also und mehr ist dazu nicht
zu sagen und das also auch andere
regierungsmitglieder
wähler das vertrauen ausgesprochen haben
muss ich ja hier nicht wiederholen also
soweit unsere belange von heute
betroffen sind sozial wahrscheinlich auf
mich am meisten an kommen und ich habe
mich ja schon klar geäußert
wenn eine frage zusammenfassen die
mehrere kolleginnen kollegen online
gestellt haben die auch angesprochen
haben der fall bayern und die
einrichtung funktionen und pflicht sie
haben gesagt was sie davon halten die
frage die jetzt anschließend kommt von
mehreren kollegen wie gehen sie damit um
was machen sie gegen sozusagen das land
bayern anführungsstrichen wird es zu
einer wie von ihnen angekündigten
einheitlichen anwendungsformen kommen
und sagen ich mache hier nicht etwas
gegen jemanden sondern wir arbeiten für
die menschen die uns anvertraut sind und
das gesetz gilt ja wir werden natürlich
weiterhin mit der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz und auch
mit einzelnen ländern also an
instrumenten arbeiten womit wir die
umsetzung unterstützen können das haben
wir ja zum teil schon gemacht zum
beispiel das faq instrument oder sehr
sehr viel genutzt was wir dazu
entwickelt haben und also
stehen den ländern auch jederzeit zur
verfügung also weiter gehende
hilfeleistung zu entwickeln die also
gesundheitsministerkonferenz hat sich ja
ganz klar zu
richtung des bezogenen impfpflicht
bekannt dass gleiche also gilt auch also
für die ministerpräsidenten in anderer
art also in anderen runter oder also in
der vergangenheit das gesetz gilt wir
werden mit allen daran arbeiten
umsetzungsmöglichkeiten zu erleichtern
aber ich muss das mal so sagen es muss
auch wirklich an wille da sein das
gesetz umzusetzen
was also nicht geht ist dass man also
jetzt so tut als wenn es die umsetzung
also probleme wären die uns hier im weg
stehen sondern man muss ja auch beim
namen nennen das ist eine unbeliebte
vollzugs maßnahme die dazu führt dass in
einigen bundesländern zumindest
zeitweise auch personal also
möglicherweise ausfällt das macht
niemand gerne und diesem konflikt also
will man offenbar ausreichen weil man
glaubt die open die omikron variante ist
so harmlos dass man das nicht mehr
braucht es ist ja und ja das zu sagen
worum es hier geht was man sich überlegt
hat also die omikron variante erlaubt es
uns dass also beschlossene gesetz nicht
umzusetzen und davor war nicht eben also
aus zwei gründen zum einen ist das eine
fehleinschätzung der oregon variante die
für ältere menschen oder für menschen
mit also immunsupprimierten situation
durchweg sehr gefährlich ist also mit
gibt es das medizinisch nicht her und
zum zweiten gibt es auch noch ein
vollkommen falsches signal weil wir
damit also den eindruck machen wie wären
politisch erpressbar
gibt es das kritisieren das gibt es
einen durchsetzungs instrument des
bundes gegenüber den ländern nein gibt
es nicht also der vollzug ist also
länder aufgabe und also wir also
können hilfestellungen an die 1000 von
uns verlangt ist also beispielsweise
wenn dies aus bayern also die frage käme
können wir eine also muster
benachrichtigung entwickeln mit der
beispielsweise die gesundheitsämter dann
also die betroffenen anschreiben und
zwar sonst das können wir sehr gerne
machen oder gibt es also beispielsweise
die anfrage an uns also wo kann so etwas
in der überprüfung ausgelagert werden
damit die gesundheitsämter nicht
überfordert sind da können wir auch
gerne helfen also wir können wirklich
mit allem helfen aber ganz konkrete
anfragen habe ich wieder aus bayern noch
von der cdu bisher gesehen das ist
offensichtlich so dass man sich hier von
dem gesetz verabschieden will und das
ist falsch war auch bekommen ist noch
lange nicht zu ende und gerade werden
wir lockern wollen dann kann es durchaus
sein dass die fallzahlen zunächst einmal
gerade bei den älteren wieder steigen
die haben bisher sehr gut geschützt das
ist ja ein punkt auf den er wieder
gerade noch einmal hingewiesen hat so
viel stärker bin und wir können auch
weil es beschrieben andere varianten
auch sehr kurzfristig nicht ausschließen
somit ist es einfach leichtfertig also
das gesetz jetzt nicht anzuhören
harrison herr lauterbach sie sind einer
der direkten adressaten des brandbrief
der initiative wir werden laut die von
tiefer vertretung aus der gesamten
republik darauf aufmerksam machen dass
schüler und schule schüler zudem
besonders betroffenen der pandemie
zählen
ersten frage teilen sie die analyse die
dort festgeschrieben wird und zweitens
haben sie vertreter der initiativen
bereits zu gesprächen eingeladen oder
werden sie das noch tun
mit dem letzten punkt an ich kann mir
sehr gut also vorstellen dass ich mit
vertretern der initiative spreche wie
sie alle wissen war ich an einer corona
unabhängigen erkältung profaner weise in
der letzten woche erkrankt so dass ich
also solche gespräche nicht also führen
konnte
warface gearbeitet
und also die inhalte sind mir also zum
teil vertraut ich bin ja auch also vater
einer teenager tochter und also war es
wie die situation ist daher ist also
diese ist die beschreibung also dass
dessen was also
vorgetragen wird das ist nicht falsch
das ist ganz klar war es aber auch immer
wieder darauf hin
ich vertrete hier wirklich alles was ich
gut beeinflussen kann aber zum teil also
muss man auch offen sein also die
schulpolitik und somit der
schutzgrad von kindern und jungen
menschen ist natürlich also für den bund
kaum möglich wir können dort helfen wo
wir helfen können
beispielsweise haben wir die also
quarantäne dauer und die situation dort
haben wir empfehlungen gemacht was auf
fünf tage zu begrenzen ich erwähne also
ich trage auch selbst regelmäßig obwohl
ich es gar nicht müsste die studienlage
vor bedeutsam tatsächlich masken ähnlich
wie zwei masken im unterricht gehen sind
uns weiter aber die schnelle antwort
also ich finde die an die anliegen der
initiative im großen und ganzen gut
vorgetragenen nachvollziehbar konnte mir
gut vorstellen dass ich da also auch mal
ein gespräch führen mit repräsentanten
und also war es aber darauf hin im
großen und ganzen ist der schutz unserer
schüler und der junge menschen
landessache und kommunale sachen
nachfrage die initiative oder die
petition wird unterstützt von
wissenschaftlern auch von solchen die
sie gelobt haben zum beispiel die
professoren hoffmann oder meyer hermann
lauterbacher wieder können sie sich auch
als personen vorstellen ebenfalls diese
initiative zu unterstützen wie das ihre
kollegen und kolleginnen tun also ich
kann das also natürlich nicht also war
das ist ja eine
initiative die sich mit forderungen an
die politik wendet und also ich bin noch
nicht an dem punkt dass ich bereit bin
forderungen haben mich selbst zu
artikulieren und
ich denke dass herr weiler und und ich
da im gleichen boot sitzen nicht wählen
aber nicht also vorgreifen ja
sie wissen ja dass das robert koch
institut die erste wenn ich das richtig
in erinnerung habe die erste einrichtung
in deutschland war die konkrete
empfehlungen ausgeschrieben hat wie in
schulen kinder zu schützen
oder wie sie geschützt werden können ich
glaube das war eben welches richtig in
erinnerung habe im september also
vielfalt im herbst 2020 also
selbstverständlich unterstütze ich das
im geiste wir möchten wir wir haben
klare empfehlungen ausgesprochen und es
gibt ja inzwischen auch s3 leitlinien
wie man kinder in schulen schützen durch
verschiedene maßnahmen und alles was da
getan werden kann das sollte getan
werden wir sollten dafür sorge tragen
dass so wenig um möglichst kinder
infiziert werden aber auch in kitas das
gilt natürlich nicht nur für schulen
dann auch für kindertagesstätten
haben keine gesetzliche handhabe der
grund bundesländer
zu zwingen aber wenn ministerpräsident
söder jetzt auf seiner haltung war dann
ist da ja ein offener konflikt sehen sie
irgendeine möglichkeit vielleicht bei
schritt entgegenzukommen die bayern und
asyl argumentiert ja dass er sorge hat
dass zu viele pflegekräfte sich ganz
einfach aus ihrem beruf zurückziehen
oder
andere einrichtungen gehen wo das
womöglich gar lockerer gehandhabt wird
also sehen sie da irgend eine
kompromisslösung und dieses signal das
wir fürchten zu verhindern auch für die
allgemeine
vielen dank also es gibt ja die er nicht
wirklich viel an kompromisslinie also
entweder gilt das gesetz auch so für
bayern oder das gesetz geht nicht und im
gesetz ist ja beispielsweise für die
also umsetzung für den vollzug noch
nicht mal seine frist vorgegeben also
wenn beispielsweise jetzt was ich falsch
wie fände aber ich bringe ich denke
einfach mal laut so dass man sich
vorstellen kann wenn es meinetwegen also
eine kommune hin ging das funktioniert
ja so also die einrichtung meldet die
ungeimpften an das gesundheitsamt das
gesundheitsamt schreibt die dann an und
dann kommt also das system das besondere
gründe vorgetragen werden ob ich
allergien gegen impfstoffe und so weiter
und so fort und dann kommt irgendwann
quasi die konsequenz für denjenigen der
ungeimpfte es beispielsweise
betretungsverbot oder arbeitsverbot und
wie lange dieser prozess geht für den
einzelnen das ist im gesetz noch
nichtmals also beschrieben da können wir
gerne wären es gewünscht wird kann wir
also vorschläge machen wer das also wir
hatten ehrlich gesagt sogar schon einen
vorschlag gemacht von dem die ländern
also in teilen also
überzeugt waren im teil noch nicht dann
spielt aber keine rolle aber tatsächlich
könnte man sich also hätte man sich in
bayern meinetwegen für die gesamte
umsetzung hätte man sich einen monat
zeit nehmen lassen können und also das
ist dies also situation somit ist gibt
es gibt hier keine frist die wir gesetzt
hätten die wir jetzt verlängern konnten
damit das gesetz umgesetzt werden kann
das ist nicht so
das ist auch nicht die position von
bayern sondern versucht einfach
unbestimmte zeit ausgesetzt in der
hoffnung die ich für vollkommen
abhängigkeit
das zu sagen in der hoffnung dass nach
rom ikon dass alles vorbei ist das ist
ja die hoffnung die läden zu holen sind
die conlife noch durch und dann war es
das dann das ist ja die also lassen das
ist und das kann das ist anders aber so
das ist eine sicht der dinge die für
einen laien komplett statthaft ist aber
so können wir als also
gesundheitspolitiker mit dem riesigen
beratungsstellen wege haben und experten
die uns beraten zum beispiel wolf ab
weil viele andere können natürlich nie
so können natürlich wir nicht denken
kollegen und dann hätte
was passt die zeitung hatte war haben
sie denn mit herrn söder schon selbst
gesprochen und was bedeutet das für die
allgemeine impfpflicht ja noch viel
umstrittener ist und deren durchführung
ja dadurch vielleicht auch in weite
ferne gerückt ist wenn sie allein herr
wieder eine kleine frage anziehsachen
man solle die maßnahme beibehalten wenn
man ihnen die besonders verletzlichen
noch weiterhin schützen müsse aber
offensichtlich will sich ein teil dieser
verletzlichen selbst hartnäckig nicht
schützen wie lange kann man das noch
aufrecht erhalten
also ich habe bisher söder bisher noch
nicht gesprochen ich schließe das aber
nicht aus weil ich mir die merkel ich im
guten direkten kontakt immer war und ich
bin gestern einfach von der also schnell
es jetzt mal botschaft überrascht worden
und was bedeutet das für die allgemeine
öffentliche bedeutet zunächst mal für
die allgemeine nebenpflicht gar nichts
das ist ja eine aufgabe des deutschen
bundestags dazu eine entscheidung zu
kommen und da
er war hatte ich im laufe der woche
entsprechende auch ganz konkrete
gesetzentwurf über die werden wir dann
also debattieren und auch der zeitrahmen
also der debatte ist also nicht
gefährdet von daher glaube ich nach wie
vor dass wir also das ziel was wir uns
vorgenommen haben schaffen können dass
wir die auch bekommen wäre gut meistern
mit möglichst also weniger schweren
fällen und wenig todesfällen bei annas
einmal
strategie wie man nachher darauf blicken
kann kann sagen das hat funktioniert und
dass wir also einen rückfall mit anderen
varianten oder nikon im herbst durch die
allgemeine impfpflicht verhindern
ja also wir haben uns daran gewöhnt dass
es auch sehr klug dass man wirklich auf
die informationen schaut die man hat
bevor man dann die entsprechenden
maßnahmen hochfährt oder runter fährt
wir reden über wenige wochen nach
unserer vorstellung ganz einfach weil
wir diesen weg der mikrowelle aber
gewisse unsicherheit und das ist der
punkt wo ich eben alle bitten kann nur
diese diese zeit noch quasi
auch auszuhalten wir haben noch
unsicherheit wie das sein wird wie viele
menschen von den alten hochhaltigen
werden im krankenhaus sein wir haben
jetzt eine leichte trendumkehr das auf
den intensivbetten die zahlen wieder
steigen das müssen wir erst mal
beobachten
und wir werden dann sehen wie hoch
wirklich die die die schwer krank die
zahlen und der schwerkranken und auch
der mit menschen sind die wir verlieren
ja wir verlieren jeden tag immer noch
menschen an dieser krankheit und das
heißt also gar nicht wird das richten
und wir gehen eigentlich von wirklich
wenigen wochen aus und dann wird man
lockern und wie gelockert wird das muss
dann eben auch wieder entschieden werden
politisch aber die maßnahmen die ich
kennen wir alle und wie sich an
stufenweise gelockert wird das sind
keine politische entscheidung
eine frage hat sich erledigt dann können
will ich gern mal kurz 3 online fragen
einschieben beginnen mit basel weg davon
dpa herr villa oder erlaubt aber wie nah
sind bilden aus ihrer sicht am pik lässt
sich das infektionsgeschehen wirklich
etwas nach so zu tage die wir bestehen
oder zeigt sich nur die grenzen des test
und weltsystems soll vom focus
fachminister aus den ländern kommen
forderung nach bei der anstehenden mpk
16 habe ich stufen pläne für öffnungen
zu verabschieden erst zwei geben
einzelhandel und deutschlandweit
abschaffen und dann die gastronomie
welche lockerung halten sie warnte davor
warnt vertretbar und eine frage von frau
kurz von einer französischen zeitung ist
es geplant dass obwohl doch bis beispiel
seine apotheker priorisierung bei den
pcr tests künftig vornehmen sollen
vielen dank
also wann kommt der peak die also wir
rechnen nach wie vor damit dass picasso
im februar kommt
allerdings kann es sich halt
herausziehen durchaus so die ba2 also im
variante die
etwas zusätzlicher ansteckung hier noch
mit sich bringt und also die in dieser
form also in die modellierung noch nicht
eingeflossen war also kann ich sagen
dass es noch etwas hin zieht aber es ist
auf jeden fall also eine sache von
wochen so wie es auch wieder geschrieben
hat und das allerdings nur wenn wir die
maßnahmen auch so bis dahin durchhalten
also wenn wir jetzt quasi öffnung
eröffnungs schritte beschließen dann
also zieht das ganze sich länger hin und
davor hatte ich einmal ein ganz starkes
statement schon gewarnt dass wir hier
also möglicherweise den verlauf
künstlich verlängern dass wir das was
wir gewonnen haben und wieder verlieren
indem wir einfach zu früh offenbar
voraus definitiv zu machen was den 16 2
angucken geht da wird ja jetzt viel
schon öffentlich diskutiert was gemacht
werden soll zweig
soll also in den geschäften fahren ich
möchte mich auch an dieser debatte nicht
teiligen sondern ich habe ich habe es
immer so dass sich die gespräche führe
mit den beteiligten und also diese
gespräche werden
spätestens also am wochenende anfang der
nächsten woche werden diese gespräche
anlaufen und das wird dann auch sehr
stark darauf abhängen wie davon abhängen
wie sich die zahlen entwickeln wir
machen jetzt auch noch mal eine ganz
genaue auswertung der situation in den
krankenhäusern
wir werden auch in den also in sehr
kurzer zeit werden wir tagesaktuelle
daten aus den krankenhäusern endlich
bekommen so also zahl der mit kubik
eingelieferten und führt eingelieferten
so dass wir das auch noch nutzen können
und davon werden die lockerungen dann
abhängen und schließt sich also
bei pharmazeutischen zeitung aber ich
frage mich ganz verstanden ist dass dort
das also ob also apotheker selbst
priorisiert werden also für die pcr test
oder ist das die frage ob die pocket
tests also mit berücksichtigt werden in
der priorisierung was was genau die
frage hat nochmals stark so ist es
geplant dass auch beispielsweise
apotheken priorisierung bei den pcr test
künftig vornehmen wollen so also
sozusagen war der also ja wenn also bei
werden eine apotheke beispielsweise wenn
ein apotheker an testzentrum ist und
also es ist ein positiver antigen test
also vorgenommen worden und das der pcr
wird dann veranlasst dann also soll da
die priorisierung stattfinden bei der
veranlassung des pc voraussetzungen dass
der anti gen test positiv war und das
können dann auch also apotheker machen
sofern sie also quasi
an das system angebunden sind und pc
also fahren lassen können was viele was
also apotheken zum teil auch können ja
wieder ja also ich ergänze diesen aspekt
der testungen die eventuell nicht
ausreichen in der in der öffentlichen
verhandlung ich möchte das noch mal
wirklich ganz entschieden klarstellen
ich habe das in der letzten
bundespressekonferenz ist ja auch schon
vorgestellt wir haben genügend systeme
wo wir wirklich genügend informationen
haben um wirklich zu wissen in welcher
phase einer pandemiewelle wir stehen ich
hatte ihnen das vorgestellt die diese
systeme die nennen wir diese sind
römische überwachung oder syndrom
geschwister williams wenn sie unseren
wochenbericht schauen vom letzten
donnerstag
da kommt ja jeden donnerstag aus da
sehen sie sehr schön wie diese sind
römischen also wirklich
krankheitsbezogenen informationen wie
die übereinstimmen mit den echten
incidents das heißt also wir haben einen
guten blick darüber ob es eine
ansteigende oder ein abfahren der pegel
und ich hatte auch gerade gesagt wir
sehen momentan ein anstieg in der
hospitalisierung inzidenz und zwar in
allen altersstufen also wir haben hier
zwei unterschiede sondern ein bisschen
59 dass eine altersgruppe die wir uns
immer an schon über 60 und dann sehen
wir in beiden altersgruppen steigen die
hospitalisierung inzidenz das sind ja
wahre klare zahlen ja das ist ein trend
und wir sehen gerade eine gewisse
trendumkehr bei den intensivstationen
das heißt also wir haben diesen
überblick wir wissen exakt was geschieht
und insofern ist dieses argument dass es
zu wenig tests gemacht wurden und man
damit keinen einblick mehr in die
pandemie hat dieser dem trete ich
entschieden entgegen wir haben diese
drei strategien sollen die habe ich auch
schon auf der welt die eindämmung den
schutz und die abmilderung und diese
verschieben sich etwas im laufe einer
pandemie welche intensiver oder weniger
intensiv gefahren werden das hatte ich
auch glaube ich vor zwei wochen
erläutert also nein diese sorge muss man
nicht haben wir haben den durchblick wir
wissen in welcher phase der pandemie wir
stehen aber noch mal wir haben zurzeit
noch nicht genügend informationen über
die alten und hochhaltigen weil das
virus wieder hauptsächlich aus den
jüngeren in diese altersgruppen
hineinkommt und wir sehen erst jetzt
wirklich hoch da die krankheitslast ist
das ist das ein ganz entscheidendes
merkmal im handel mit
hard weil er eine frage an sie hat ja
auf die wichtigkeit des globalen
hilfsprogramms hingewiesen wie bewerten
sie vor diesem hintergrund dass länder
wie deutschland selbst große mengen
impfstoff
zurückhaltend um kinder zu pusten sollte
deutschland sozusagen aber der effekt
der nutzen marginal ist sollte
deutschland ihrer ansicht nach mehr
impfstoff dosen weltweit ländern zur
verfügung stehen wo noch nicht mal zehn
prozent der bevölkerung geimpft sind
also ich glaube weltweit muss man halt
die impfstoff kapazitäten einfach
hochfahren und
ich will jetzt nicht auf deutschland sie
eingehen aber europa insgesamt ist ja
ein großer produzent von impfstoffen und
mehr als die hälfte so viel ich weiss
verlässt euro und wird in anderer länder
geliefert kein anderer großer
regionaler blog liefert so viele hoch
wirksame impfstoffe in die in die welt
hinaus das heißt aber nicht dass es
perfekt ist und dass man das nicht noch
beschleunigen muss weil sich auch betont
habe ist die wichtigkeit von
hochwirksamen
impfstoffen und die werden besonders
hier in europa hergestellt also
beispielsweise große teile südamerikas
sind mit sie nowak und ähnlichen
geimpfte die bei omikron so gut wie
keinen schutz bieten dass das nur da
kann man aktiv gegensteuern indem man
halt hilft dass noch mehr impfstoffe
produziert werden und schnell geliefert
werden und zu grosser im braten in
diesen ländern führt
eine nachfrage am bieler noch asiaten
vierzehnter januar ihren der
bundespressekonferenz mit großer
bestimmtheit gesagt das die zahl der
intensivpatienten steigen wird und auch
die zahl der täglichen todesfälle jetzt
knapp vier wochen später ist es nicht
eingetreten die zahl der
intensivpatienten ist 20 prozent
niedriger die zahl der todesfälle 30
prozent niedriger als damals nun sie
sagen haben sie sich geirrt oder ist
eine gewisse
worst case kommunikation aus ihrer sicht
notwendig um die bevölkerung zu
bestimmten maßnahmen zu bewegen na ja
sie müssen sehen dass sich die zahlen
der delta variante also die abnahme auf
den intensivbetten
bezieht sich hauptsächlich auf die
aufnahme der delta patienten wie in den
betten liegen und längere zeit liegen
wir haben jetzt ja ein anstieg auf den
zahlen und zwar der beruht auf der
omicron variante das heißt die online
variante diejenigen die ihn auf intensiv
liegen und mit micon infiziert wenn ist
seitdem kontinuierlich gestiegen wir
können immer nur die situation so
bewerten wie uns daten zur verfügung
stehen ich sagte ja auch gerade wir
erleben jetzt gerade wieder einen
rebound das heißt also die
intensivbetten gehen wieder hoch und das
ist ja ein wichtiger grund warum war
einfach die maßnahmen noch mehr zeit
auch wirklich offen halten müssen wenn
unser ziel ist es doch so viel möglichst
leben und auch schwere krankheitsfälle
wie möglich ist also schwer kalkar zu
vermeiden und leben zu retten und ich
denke da ist es am wichtigsten wenn man
die fakten die einem zur hand liegt
entsprechend ausfällt
wir machen weiter mit dem kollegen ganze
sie hätten sich gemeldet ganz in den
letzen drei nicht hat sie sich nicht
gemeldet hier doch dann der kollege
fabian busch von web.de und gmx
lauterbach hätte ein etwas allgemeinere
frage an sie wie hat sich ihr blick auf
die pandemie politik verändert oder was
haben sie auch vielleicht gelernt seit
die minister sind
also politik die wir in deutschland
machen die kannte ich ja auch schon aus
früheren funktionen als
bundestagsabgeordneter und aus
beratender also wissenschaftlich waren
viele entscheidungen miteinbezogen von
da war nicht vieles ganz neu
ich glaube dass also wir in der zeit der
letzten
wochen und monaten noch einmal sehr viel
mehr wert darauf gelegt haben dass das
was wir machen wissenschaftlich also gut
abgesichert ist ich habe mich ja selbst
dafür
eingesetzt dass wir einen expertenrat
aufbauen und habe auch an der besetzung
sehr aktiv mitgearbeitet das kann ich
ihnen hier noch einmal versichern und
also auch die zusammenarbeit mit
externen wissenschaftlern ist noch
einmal intensiviert worden und auch die
art und weise wie wir also über
maßnahmen entsprechen also von daher
also ist das definitiv etwas worauf ich
selbst also viel wert gelegt hatte und
was ich auch umsetzen konnte und ich
glaube das hat das hat aus meiner sicht
früher auch stattgefunden aber weniger
systematisch das also glaube ich seine
veränderung und die ich auch
ausdrücklich begrüße dann gibt es immer
noch unsicherheiten aber diese
unsicherheiten also wir sind dann doch
also sehr viel enger beschrieben als
also wenn man nicht so vorgeht und
ansonsten also bin ich also
bemüht und auch sehr ehrgeizig darin
dass wir gut durch diese mikrowelle
kommen ich glaube das ist im großen und
ganzen osten gründig im ersten stellt
mit also noch mal vorgetragen hat dass
wir im großen und ganzen auf dem
richtigen weg sind und es wird mir hatte
viel ausmachen wenn wir einen schweren
rückfall im erbst verhindern könnten das
würde bedeuten wenn wir durch die
allgemeine impfpflicht einen schweren
rückfall im herbst also verhindern
könnten
dann will ich noch mal zwei drei fragen
online zusammenfassen die erste frage
gilt für apothekerinnen und apotheker
die gegen coop 19 in apotheken impfen
ebenfalls die kugel 19 impfpflicht also
sind sie teil des gesundheitswesens dann
der einrichtung gezogen ich glaube nicht
zweite frage von herrn holstein apotheke
adhoc wenn pcr pop knapp test so wichtig
sind werden sie dann die vergütung für
die apotheken anpassen die derzeit nicht
die beschaffungskosten decken und er
holt von n-tv fragt ein wlan nach den
signalen der letzten woche aus
bundesländer haben viele menschen mit
positiven schnelltests keine pcs mehr
bekommen oder von sich aus darauf
verzichtet wie hoch schätzt die daraus
folgende und der erfassung
qualifizierten und dann die minister
haben recht heute haben sie heute eine
kehrtwende vollzogen nachdem sie es
zuletzt hieß es soll nicht mehr jeder
bürger mit positiven schnelltest einen
anspruch auf pcr tests haben oder sind
sie dann missverstanden
fangen wir mit den apothekern an aus so
der apotheker ist natürlich somit
weiterhin kann also
klassischer medizinischer
leistungserbringer und fällt somit nicht
unter die impfpflicht wobei ich
allerdings fest davon ausgehe dass die
apotheker also sich also freiwillig
impfen und jeder kann also dass wir da
ganz vollzugsprobleme haben
der zweite teil der fall hatte dazu den
bock nazis und den versuch bookmarks es
genauso wir arbeiten einer erhöhung der
vergütung mein eindruck ist der dass die
also vergütung derzeit nicht
kostendeckend ist und wir sind
diesbezüglich also mit dem
bundesfinanzministerium sind wir im
engen austausch
dass wir da also zu einer lösung
hinkommen und ich vereinfache die letzte
frage und gleich mit also ist das eine
kehrtwende das dann doch der anspruch
auf den pcr bestehen bleibt derweil ich
also eine vergangenheit vorgetragen
hatte dass dieser anspruch nicht mehr
gedeckt sei durch die zahl der pc aus
die wir haben das in der tat also eine
veränderung der position weil wir auf
der grundlage der modellierung der welle
die wir jetzt also
sehen davon ausgehen können dass wir es
in dieser kombination also an antike
interessen feuer gemacht und dann
bestätigen der pcr gemacht dass wir
ausreichend pcr tests haben von daher
also haben wir eine also ich sage mal
verbesserung der strategie vornehmen
können auf der grundlage einer also
modellierung die darauf hinausläuft dass
wir also wahrheit über die 400.000 fälle
pro tag nicht weggehen können also die
test verordnungs strategie die ich hier
gerade beschrieben habe die würden auch
sehr auskömmlich funktionieren gut
funktionieren bis hin zu instanzen von
etwa 450.000 pro tag und ich glaube dass
wir das nicht erreichen werden ja die
unter erfassung nimmt in allen ländern
natur nicht zu je höher die
infektionsraten sind da gibt es eine
menge gründe dafür das ist nicht nur der
grund dass die tests dass die tests
nicht mehr so viele der infektion
erfassen sondern es gibt natürlich auch
einfach die gründe dass gerade bei
omikron wo es ja einige vier oder mehr
milde verläufe geht als bei anderen dass
dort auch einfach nicht mehr getestet
wird und den menschen auch entsprechend
selber zu hause bleiben in isolation
gehen
diese untererfassung die berechnen wir
dadurch dass wir eben serologische
studien durchführen ich bin nicht sicher
ob ich die studien die wir alle durch
stehen dir mal vorgestellt habe eine
studie die führen wir zusammen mit dem
soziologischen
soziologischen panel durch und das ist
eine sehr sehr gute stichprobe die eine
hohe repräsentativität hat die wird
gerade im moment auch durchgeführt und
ich gehen wir davon aus dass wir nach
ostern wissen wie hoch die unter
erfassung gewesen ist und dann haben wir
auch einen guten einblick darin wie
viele menschen in unserem land denn
schon kontakt mit dem virus hatten das
ist natürlich wichtig gerade wenn wir
uns dann auf den herbst vorbereiten wir
wissen ja dass im herbst sicher wieder
mehr fälle auftauchen auch mit anderen
atemwegsinfektionen und dann ist
natürlich ganz gut zu wissen wie hoch
ist denn eine gewisse immunität in der
bevölkerung es wird dann mit modelliert
dass das glaube ich ist die wichtigste
information ich sage aber nochmal
dadurch dass er diese syndrom ische
überwachung haben sehen wir was an
krankheitslast wirklich dort ist das
reicht aus um das abschätzen zu können
erklären wir sind etwas drüber unsere
zeit ich habe noch drei fragen hier
verlässt und eine frage online die würde
ich gerne machen wir fangen er mit der
anderen erhöhungen der jessen und eine
online frage
marbecker sehr wichtig vermerkten partei
watson herr lauterbach in österreich
kann jetzt schon zur schule streiks
gegen die durchseuchung oder wegen der
durch solche und deutschland könnte es
auch passieren haben sie dafür
verständnis und wenn sie jetzt noch
schüler werden würden sie sich an
solchen streiks beteiligen
ja so
diese lage in österreich kann nicht
schlecht kommentieren weil ich sie vor
ort nicht einschätzen kann und ob ich
mich selbst an einem solchen stark
beteiligung wurde das glaube ich eher
nicht aber
da will ich auch kein vorbild während
jemand sagen das würde auch nichts zu
sache tun aber ich kann tatsächlich die
situation in der station spur
beurteilen es ist durchweg verständlich
dass gerade kinder und junge erwachsene
also mit dass sie die situationen im
moment nicht zufrieden sein können das
muss doch gar so sagen weil die
fallzahlen sind also nicht vertretbar
sind sehr hoch der schutz scheint nicht
also in dem maße zu funktionieren wie er
funktionieren müsste und wir wissen ja
auch dass bei kindern zu längeren
verläufen kommen kann somit also ist das
eine situation die man nicht beschönigen
darf und die wir ernst nehmen
der junge
herr papa ich habe noch eine persönliche
frage an sie wird sicher darauf
hingewiesen haben dass kann auf dem plan
planeten sicher ist wenn ich alle auf
dem planeten sicher sind hier geht es um
die patent freigabe für die impfstoffe
wie stehen sie dazu die bundesregierung
mit hilfe der eu schützt ja lieber die
pharmaindustrie stadt die patente
freizugeben wie von der whu der wto den
großteil der welt und auch die usa
gefordert jetzt und pflanzen und weitere
news haben wir auch aufgezeigt dass es
über 100 standorte in asien
lateinamerika und afrika aktuell schon
gibt die sofort mlm stoffe produzieren
könnten
finden sie die haltung der
bundesregierung die patent freigabe zu
blockieren richtig
also die die frage der patente freigabe
ist eine sehr interessante weit
einerseits wäre natürlich sehr schön
wenn man möglichst viel impfstoff
produzieren kann das ist auf jeden fall
ein ziel ob das durch die patent
freigabe passieren würde ist
umstritten
aber was sie vielleicht auch wissen ist
dass es
bestrebungen gibt halt
impfstoffproduktion auch von moderner
impfstoffen aufzuziehen ohne patente zu
verletzten in südafrika ist gerade so
eine
produktion angelaufen und es gibt auch
bestrebungen der ganzen unternehmen
überlizenzierung die
produktionsstandorte zu vergrößern ich
glaube da ist noch viel potenzial drin
und ich kann beide seiten der debatte
verstehen ich weiß nicht wer in diesem
fall genau die besseren argumente hat
aber es ist auf jeden fall wichtig
sowohl die impfstoffproduktion zu
erhöhen wo hochwirksamen stoffen und
jede weltweit zur verfügung zu stellen
aber auch und das möchte ich auch noch
mal betonen es ist nicht mehr sind nicht
nur die impfstoffe das ist nicht nur
sauerstoff 2 es ist die globale
gesundheitsfürsorge solange es
immungeschwächte patienten gibt die auf
zwei kriegen bestehe immer die gefahr
dass daraus neue besorgniserregende
varianten entstehen wir müssen die
gesundheitsfürsorge weltweit
verbessern die sogenannten neglected
tropical diseases müssen weltweit
wirklich mal angegangen werden nicht nur
von von der gates-stiftung oder in
kontrast sondern von den entwickelten
nationen um solche probleme
zurückzudrängen
er ist die frage geht an herrn villa und
herrn lauterbach in der vergangenen
woche war hier in der
bundespressekonferenz thema die frage ob
zusätzliche stellen für die stiko die
zugesagt worden sind ob es ob das
tatsächlich neue stellen werden oder ob
sie den personalbestand rkg entnommen
werden an anderer stelle da konnte in
der vergangenen woche die
bundesregierung keine auskunft geben ist
inzwischen klarheit geschaffen wieder
müssen sie das aus dem vorhandenen
bestand aus schlitten oder herr
lauterbach gibt es da echte neue stellen
zur unterstützung der stiko ja also
zunächst noch mal in ergänzung was
apweiler gesagt habe ich möchte das auch
noch mal betont allein das
robert-koch-institut hat während dieser
corona pandemie mehr als 70 länder
unterstützt beim aufbau von
diagnostischen einheiten bei der beim
aufbau auch von von
impfstrategien sie dürfen nie vergessen
auch im land im ausland es gibt leider
auch in vielen ländern gerade in einigen
afrikanischen ländern gibt es eine hohe
impfskepsis und doch gibt es sehr viele
menschen die sich gar nicht impfen
lassen auch wenn die impfstoffe vor ort
in das heißt auch diese
sozioökonomischen aspekte muss man alle
im blick haben also
allein das robert-koch-institut schon
einiges ist das nur ein institut von
vielen tatsächlich haben wir sieben
stellen bekommen die sieben stellen sind
aber nicht mit finanzmittel hinterlegt
das bedeutet dass sie sie aus wenn ich
das richtig verstehe außerdem fahren die
personalbestand an anderer stelle nehmen
könnten was die arbeit des lka hat dann
vielleicht sprechen sollte lauterbach
wäre es nicht sinnvoll dann tatsächlich
für neue stellen auch eine finanzierung
zu sorgen der vorgang wird auf jeden
fall geprüft und also ich bin einfach um
verständnis dafür dass zunächst einmal
im vordergrund stand sofort diese
stellen zur verfügung zu stellen so dass
also die arbeiter stiko also sich
beschleunigen kann ich weiß nicht ob das
in dem zusammenhang zu sehen ist aber
wir haben ja jetzt auch sehr schnelle
beschlüsse zum beispiel bei der
fertigung von der stiko gesehen
möglicherweise also
schon mit auswirkungen zu tun und ich
nehme das aber einfach mit also dass
eine auskömmliche finanzierung also hier
notwendig es ist ganz klar aber also
hier musste erst einmal sehr schnell
gehandelt wäre das hatte ich auch
zugesagt das hat stattgefunden dann
kommt die letzte frage heute online von
frau wolff vom gesundheitspolitischen
informationstiefe lauterbach da die
varianten bildung zwar zurückgedrängt
werden kann aber sich doch immer wieder
im mund implementierten personen oder in
der tierwelt ereignen kann ist daraus
nicht dann die konsequenz dass das
monitoring und das jährliche ergreifen
von maßnahmen auch nie mehr enden wird
nie mehr sollte man nicht sagen aber ich
sehe die also situationen so ähnlich wie
ihr außerdem ich danke dass er heute mit
an bord ist das so weil ich seine
studien auch gut kenne und
wir haben halt die situation dass es
sehr unwahrscheinlich ist das ist nicht
zu neuen varianten kommt und es ist auch
sehr unwahrscheinlich dass neue
varianten immer harmloser sind als die
varianten die es gab dafür gibt es
überhaupt keinen leider muss man sagen
überhaupt keinen also virologisch
epidemiologischen grund und also das was
herr ab weil er eben den vordergrund
gestellt das was er sich nicht
vorstellen kann aber es ist tatsächlich
so also die varianten also die bauen
nicht aufeinander auf sondern die kommen
aus der ursprungs variante und werden
immer noch von dort weg geschossen und
von viele von diesen varianten mit denen
jetzt möglicherweise noch zu tun
bekommen die gibt es bereits
sie sind irgendwo in also menschen schon
auch so in der weiterentwicklung
die werden schon von irgend jemandem der
in vielleicht immunsupprimierten ist
also getragen vielleicht sogar in tieren
somit also ist also das noch leider muss
man sagen nicht zu ende und ich glaube
nicht dass wir von nie sprechen können
aber die also
theorie die immer vorgetragen wird das
ist beim virus so dass es zuerst ein
paar gefährliche variante sind dann
fängt es an harmloser zu werden und
irgendwann das ist dann so harmlos was
sie uns über geht das ist leider zu
schön um wahr zu sein und hat wenig
sofort hat wenig fundament ist leider so
dass ich das meer so vorstellen als wenn
man das ursprungsvirus hat was also sich
dann entwickelt hat um unterschiedliche
richtungen und all diese richtungen die
sind irgendwo liegen die noch um und
also dann kann hier etwas plötzlich groß
werden und hier kann etwas groß wären
hier kann etwas großes werden das ist
nicht so dass das aufeinander aufbaut
und dieser punkt ist also sehr bedeutsam
und ich glaube da teilen wir auch die
einschätzung dass darin die gefahr liegt
daher ist etwas
raus ab das team macht also wofür ich
mich in deutschland auch schon also vor
längerer zeit eingesetzt hat also was
sie auch mit dem robert koch institut
zusammen also gemacht dass man überwacht
ob es neue varianten gibt das ist von
größter bedeutung dass von allergrößter
bedeutung
nun auch dass diese information
kostenfrei zur verfügung steht als
public use file also das ist also etwas
was über jahre hinweg noch benötigen
werden über viele jahre hinweg glaube
ich noch eine sache ergänzte der
minister hat es schon diesen teil
wirklich gut beschrieben aber ich möchte
auch darauf hinweisen es gibt ja auch
die notwendigkeit dass wir
vorbereitet sind auf weitere pandemien
die passieren werden und ich möchte auf
dem artikel der letzte woche nature
erschienen worden erschienen ist der in
weißen und der dann
kommentar dazu in science in dem
wissenschaftler hingegangen sind haben
einfach mal alle öffentlich verfügbaren
daten
rohdaten genomdaten nach rna viren
durchsucht und sie hatten zehntausende
ich glaube 130000 neue rna viren
gefunden die noch nicht beschrieben
waren das war sozusagen beifang von
anderen studien sekundär benutzen
schon vorhandenen forschungsdaten
darunter waren etliche coronaviren
beispielsweise 30 neue
verwandte von hepatitis delta all diese
all diesen viren und viele die wir gar
nicht kannten bisher haben alle dass
das risiko dass sich aus so was
auszulosen dann auch wieder
neue pandemie entwickeln können und da
müssen wir darauf vorbereitet sein und
da gibt es halt maßnahmen wie genomische
überwachung die nicht nur für für viren
und wichtig ist auch für tuberkulose für
eine antimikrobielle resistenzen und so
weiter die überwachung der der der
genomsequenzen in kläranlagen ist super
frühwarnsystem das man halt weiter
ausbauen kann hoffen alle dass die
lehren die wir jetzt gezogen haben aus
der jetzigen krise wirklich
rübergebracht werden in eine neue
generation von public health monitoring
das weltweit verknüpft ist also man kann
auch wirklich manchmal aus einer krise
in den stoff wird werden das tun
vielen dank herr minister meine herren
danke ihnen